we we weren't a professional hockey team
so we didn't have the money to go and
travel and play exhibition games we
literally turned up to the world
championships and played our first game
and it was just like we don't even know
how we going to perform against
Australia or Austria or Hungary or
whatever so let's test it let's test
everything let's try it welcome back to
the show my name is heam isus and on
this week's episode I was joined by
Andrew Sil I started playing street
hockey when I was a kid like 8 n years
old and just got lucky I always thinking
myself as getting lucky we didn't have
any ice rinks where I lived so I I just
fell into hockey we did have the best
roller disco though in the country now
I've known Andrew for some time we
actually sat down quite a while back to
record a face tof face podcast and this
time round we got together to discuss
his recent published book called player
coach Andrew wanted to give the
recruitment industry a gift by
distilling all of his wisdom his
principles his insights from supporting
and working with over 3,000 billing
managers which he likes to call player
coaches so he distills how to be a
successful player coach into 10 laws and
in this conversation we break down each
law and why it is a law in Andrew's eyes
so Andrew is now the founder of Team
head coach and we have a great
partnership with Andrew at Hector so
hopefully this conversation these laws
these principles these insights from
Andrew will massively help you what have
you found to be the most effective way
to to hold hold people accountable in
terms of like consistency best way to
describe it as a let's get into this
week's
episode Andrew welcome to the podcast H
him my man it's good to see you likewise
sat down a real long time ago few times
when we was yeah when we was in uh o
when he was on the
podcast a while back it was in the
studio when I was working for sha hawo
yeah yeah uh in East London the the
depths of East London came in yeah I
remember walking through that area
thinking what's going on here where
where are you taking me literally um so
obviously we we've got to know each
other over a long period of time
obviously doing some really cool things
together now so I'm I'm excited to sort
of have this conversation with you I
think just to frame it up for everyone
what we're looking to do this
conversation before I get you to
introduce yourself for those that may
not know sort of who you are your story
but you recently which you like to call
the gift to the recruitment industry
written a book called player coach which
is all about how to stay remain top
biller whilst building a winning team um
and scale faster so I know you've done
hours and hours and hours of work with
people in our industry that are often
described uh to be in the most difficult
seat in the industry which is the
billing manager role and
you know with what we do at Hector a lot
of people that deliver training for us
are people in that player coach role and
I think that those types of people i'
I've found are often some of the most
underserved people in the industry in
terms of support development which is
why I think this this book like the
amount of people that you've helped
worked with is um yeah amazing so what
we're going to do is we're going to find
out why Andrew even you know put this
book together um how this came about but
also we're going to go through uh this
book in this conversation and you've
broken down this player coach uh roll
into 10 laws and we're going to break
down what those 10 laws are to all of
you listening who maybe are aspiring to
become a manager or in a player coach
role right now can hopefully you know
maximize that position that you're in uh
see yeah so let's Andrew give us you
know for people that don't know who you
are give us the the background cuz I
think you you know your story is pretty
unique and I really like the you know
the the mix of um you know the the
sports uh part of your life and also
then you know the coaching uh part of
your life so tell us a bit about you
know who you are and for those that may
not know who you are y well I'm a best
way to describe it as a former
International athlete turned head coach
International head coach turned business
psychologist that's probably the the
road map I started playing street hockey
when I was a kid like eight nine years
old and just got lucky I always thinking
myself as getting lucky we didn't have
any ice rinks where I lived so I I just
fell into street hockey we did have the
best roller disco though in the
country spent my Saturday nights in a
roller disco and then ended up just
playing hockey and traveling around
Europe and then ended up pursuing it
professionally I moved to Canada played
down in California had an amazing
experience I'm in this back in the late
90s so I'm showing my age a little bit
now and then I I stopped playing in 2010
started coaching at the same time I was
working at S3 so I I'd taken on this job
at S3 as and my role was to help create
a coaching and feedback culture there so
very much immersed I had an awesome team
and we started designing content to help
S3 develop the leaders I was doing
Executive
coaching and what was great about it is
I was coaching the British team at the
same time so I was sharing these kind of
anecdotal these challenges I was kind of
building you know this concept of
building in public it was kind of the
first time I started actually saying
this is my biggest challenge right now I
don't know how to be Austria and sharing
this journey so I think added a bit of
credibility with the with the the
leaders there that I was on this kind of
mission if you like we had a lot of
success with a British team uh we had
kind of an historic moment and and also
at the same time I was observing this
this challenge around growth at S3 you
know and S3 was very much very bought
into the Billy manager role you know the
the whole concept of scaling it's it
kind of the Legacy there and I think a
lot of this conversation around bilding
manager is probably S3 Legacy I'm sure
it exists in in some of the other
businesses as well but when I left S3 in
2012 I was I I went straight into
Consulting works I was traveling around
the Middle East EUR Europe us working
with like 14 500 companies i' done a
masters in organizational psychology and
I was really going into this deep into
management
consulting but it was it's kind of
causing a bit of a strain on on me and
my family my health and at the same time
I was getting these inquiries from
recruitment business owners saying look
you know that work you did at S3 can you
come and help us with um some of our
leaders and it just grew from there and
then it just shifted from management
consulting with Fortune 500s being 99%
of my work to 99% of my work being with
recruitment companies and we're forming
some strategic
Partnerships and I was having so much
more fun you know it's like you know you
know the recruitment industry it's just
it's just good people focused you know I
think as far as Sports and business are
concerned conned those two that like the
recruitment industry is is about as
close to high performance sports for an
industry you're going to get right so so
it served me really well I've had 10
years now or just over 10 years serving
recruitment companies helping them
develop their leaders I would say that
now 90% of my work is working with CEOs
so I'm I'm doing more Executive coaching
with the CEO and then typically what
happens is we start having a
conversation about growth and scaling
and and developing their leaders so they
either put one or two of their billing
managers on our on our course or they've
got enough to run it in house and that's
what I'm doing so we run the player
coach course and that's how it's come
about and and I was just thinking you
know I I can't scale this as much as I'd
like to the best way to scale it is to
write a book you know why don't I just
put it all into a book share my story
share my experience of being a player
coach myself billing manager not in
recruitment but I worked at Yellow Pages
I've always worked in sales I was a
player coach for team Great Britain back
in 2006 and so I I'm I'm bringing
together these principles to help biling
managers and it you know the feedback is
it's just practical it works you know if
I do the if I follow these steps you
know the system then then it works as
soon as I stop following the
system you know things start to unravel
a little bit and you've and you've
helped what I was looking on I think you
put on your website that you've helped
over like
3,000 managers something like that yeah
I mean if you include the 3 or 400 S3
and then the two 300 a year that that
we've worked with over the last 10 years
and then those that have just taken on
the online program then possibly it
could be I don't know it could be more
but you know if you include the on like
people just doing it by themselves and
like you said the the system that you
often talk about is what you've
distilled in this book right yeah
exactly um so yeah I think it'll be fun
to just go through this together so
people listening who might be in that
seat right now or aspiring to um can
hope hopefully yeah like uh hopefully
perform better in in that R cuz it is
really difficult it's a stressful role
you know and you know I talk about that
and well-being and I I don't talk about
it in a fluffy way but if if you if
you're organized you can you can make it
work but it like any sales job or sales
management job it's the best job in the
world the worst job in the world you
know if we don't stay on top of it so
yeah hopefully it can help so let let's
break this down so you you broken it
down into two into 10 laws but like two
sections you've got the found
and then you've got the Playbook let
let's start with the the foundations
which I'm assuming is like you have to
have this right before we talk about the
other stuff yeah I think the foundations
I think of as a mindset but there's
definitely a skill element to it as well
you know so like the first one is I
don't tell right so and this has come
from my experience of of being a sales
manager myself and making that that era
of of being a high performing
salesperson going into a Sales
Management role and just telling people
to do exactly what I did and you'll be
really successful and in some ways
following you know some of a of a
blueprint of course there are some
Basics certainly recruitment that you
have to follow to be
successful but it it's there there's a
process to that you know you got to
train them first but if you keep telling
them what to do because they're not
performing well or whatever and I was
doing that as a Sal manager I did I
somehow even with everything I knew back
in 2010 when I took on a head coach job
for Great Britain I went in with kind of
dactic approach and you know telling
players how we're going to play what
we're going to do what we're going to
achieve and I just got lots of
resistance so it was a real light bulb
moment and when I'm working with leaders
and they start to realize the power of
of asking good questions not
manipulative questions sometimes people
get get it wrong and they think if I
just ask a question and I get the answer
I want I'm coaching no you're not if you
if you know the answer to the question
you're asking just tell them it's not
that we're not trying to steer them to
the answer but being curious believing
that people are creative that they've
got intuition even someone on day one
you know a recruitment job of course
they're not going to have the in-depth
knowledge but you can ask them a
question they've got some gut feel if
you create an environment where people
feel confident to to share ideas to
bring some Innovation but it all comes
from the leader questions that you it's
the ability to ask really good questions
we do it in sales we do it when we are
when we're work working with clients and
then sometimes do the exact opposite
with our people so um that to me is is
is the number one skill that every
leader should double down on is the
ability to ask questions help people
think and it should feel challenging for
people it shouldn't be easy yeah so what
I write down is you put seek first to
understand and then to be understood
yeah step kovy quote stepen kovi you
know that that you know going into these
conversations without an agenda
sometimes is is important particularly
with mentoring so let's just bring this
to life a bit give us maybe an example
of if I'm a player coach right now and
I'm I don't have this like what you've
seem to be like the the seem to say the
number one skill that I really need to
get better at and work on what does like
telling people sound like in a
recruitment context like what what does
that s what might that sound
like
example be taller be taller is I mean
it's what it sounds like you know it's
like that's what it sounds like to the
person it's like saying to a 5 fo4
basketball player wants to the NBA be
told
you know so we're just constantly kind
of as an analogy you know it's that's
what it feels like for the consultant so
be faster do more make more calls you
know it's it's all sort of just just
talking about the output you know and
you know ask these questions say this
say this you know get it over the line
you want to get the deal over the line
you know I don't think it happens as
much now but I used to see manager
literally in their ear of the consultant
tell telling them what to say next you
know rather than use it as anity to
spend some time after that call to to
reflect and ask some questions you know
and do you think that also what what
Springs to mind for me when you're
giving those examples is I feel like
that really damages the feeling of
agency like if my manager just telling
me like do this like do this do more of
this yeah I'm I'm not I don't feel like
I'm going to feel any sort of like
ownership or yeah agency of like what
I'm doing and I'm just trying to keep my
manager happy which I don't think is
yeah exactly sustainable way to be happy
in my role or perform well in my role
consistently absolutely we know what
motivates people if you look at Daniel
Pink's work in surprising truth about
what motivates Us in drive you know
purpose give me clarity about what what
I'm supposed to do when people say
they've got a motivation problem I would
say 99% of the time they don't have a
motivation problem they have a Clarity
problem the person isn't exactly sure
what they're supposed to be working on
that day or they've got too many things
to focus on so purpose is is key
autonomy you know let me do it my way
then let me figure this out I know what
the beginning is I know what the end is
because you've asked me the questions
and you framed it that way and then
Mastery let me let me master this let me
let me develop the skill give me the
space give me the tools give me the
resources to develop Mastery so when
we've got purpose autonomy and Mastery
those three things together will drive
motivation they'll drive you know
getting in the zone you know using the
athletes kind of language or dropping
into flow you get into that high
productive High Peak Performance mindset
when you give people that space What
does what does ask sound like then
Andrew in a player coach role what does
ask sound like in a bilding manager
role H what what's your biggest
challenge right
now that's totally different and that
makes me feel totally
different yeah what where where do you
want to get to by the end of the month
you know or tell me what the highlights
were of your last podcast you know what
went well you know what would you done
differently on that podcast what
questions would you asked differently in
that podcast you know talk me through
that so what when I see you on the next
podcast what will I see different well
I'll last this question so whether it's
a podcast whether it's a sales call
whether it's a pitch a meeting that
someone's just had you know it's it it's
I always say to people particularly when
you're mentoring you know and we'll talk
about bench coaching versus mentoring
bench coaching is in the game right you
are observing good stuff I know we're
probably getting ahead of the game a
little bit here with the the laws
but sometimes people confuse bench
coaching with mentoring they're two
different things bench coaching is a r
retrospective conversation something
just happened we watch the game Let's
analyze it let's talk about it or we I
listen to the call with you or I just
watch you deliver that pitch or let's
talk about the highlights of the
week um the mentoring G the mentoring
conversation is more about getting
people away from the game and asking
different questions and I always say to
people if if you're going to have a
mentoring conversation it's going to
it's either going to be you downloading
on them for 90% of the time and they're
just going to zone out you know you're
going to go through a checklist of kpis
and just are they green or red or Amber
and it's a really dull
conversation or you going to say to them
hey we've got half an hour what do you
want to focus
on what's the goal of this
conversation and for some people that
they'll be a rabbit in headlights with
that particularly if it's different to
what they're used to when you say to
someone we've got 45 minutes 1 hour what
are we focusing on today what's your
biggest
challenge chances are if they're not
used to that they will struggle with
that conversation but people forget that
developing mentoring skills and coaching
skills is one thing but the people that
are being coached and being mentored
have to learn how to be coached and
mentored because they have to do the
work because for the most part people
are inherently lazy you know they just
tell me what to do Isam like I'm got TI
you know I just want to get out there
and you know I'm struggling with this
Market's bad just tell me what to do in
a bad Market tell me what to do with a
difficult client tell me what to do a
candidate doesn't want this role
whatever it is you know
versus well let's have a conversation
about that and you tell me if you're in
the shoes of that candidate what does
that candidate need from you right now
and how will you about go about showing
up in that way you know and asking
questions that just move it from you
speaking 80% of the time to the the
person you're coaching speaking 80% of
the time and you're asking questions you
know the rule of thumb is 20 is 7030
8020 if you can get to that point then
you're doing doing really well and um
and so every mentoring conversation's
got to have a beginning and an end right
so if if we're starting a conversation
with what's your biggest challenge right
now okay what does good look like in the
next 30 days for you where do you want
to get to where where are you right now
what's going on for you right now now
we've got a beginning of the journey and
we've got an end but often what happens
is the conversation just goes ends up in
this swirl we end up trying to fix the
problem and brainstorming around it we
leave the meeting and we go then we get
annoyed
because the consultant hasn't done what
what they said they were kind of said
what they're going to do and for the
most part it's
because we haven't helped that person
understand what the end goal is we
haven't helped understand what the
beginning is we haven't helped them
brainstorm and and choose the best
option and then we haven't said to them
okay when do you want to get this done
by okay let's check in on Friday
afternoon see where you got to and if
you don't check in on Friday afternoon
to see where they got to guess what's
going to happen
they're going to think easy life and my
boss doesn't hold me
accountable so you know and and and I
try and encourage people to think about
the the best managers they've had for
the most part it's the ones that were
tough you know that held them
accountable were challenging and helped
them grow as people you know that people
look back and go I I used to have these
amazing conversations with my boss they
were hard they were tough they were
quite challenging but I was always come
out of a goal and I always came out
feeling 10t
tall that's that's what you want you're
not just battered you know love that kpi
batter just just to um just to bring
this home then you mentioned a fishbowl
exercise yeah you'd like to do tell us a
bit about tell us a bit about that CU
that could be something that people
could experiment with yeah well you can
do it in your team so we and we did this
we ran a program last year with Frank
group with their senior directors and it
was it was great and we we Ed the
Fishbowl activity there and you
basically get two people in in the
middle and so let's say it's me and in
the middle and you've got people sat
around the outside watching our
conversation and you're coaching me and
my your job is to help me formulate my
objective for the next 90 days right and
work through what some of the problems
might be and where I am now and and so
on and during that conversation you
might get stuck right so you might get
stuck with I'm stuck here I don't know
what question to ask Andrew next and if
someone notic that on the outside they
can tap you on the shoulder jump in your
chair you jump in their chair and you
now watch and that person carries the
conversation on oh nice love that and
it's a really good way for teams to one
do a bit of innovation we we have a
framework as well the cope model anyone
that's been on our course will know the
cope model uh it's a fstep plan so it's
basically getting people to think about
what what was the objective what's the
outcome where are you now what resources
you need do a bit of brainstorming
choose the best option right let's
execute let's put it into a smart
objective and and go for it test it
refine it Etc stay agile um but that
exerise itself is just a really good way
for people one to understand what some
of the challenges everybody in the
team's facing and experiencing so it
gives them Insight you know into that it
gives him empathy makes him feel like
okay I'm not the only person in this
rout in this team that's got the same
challenge or problem and uh we can all
solve it together so it's just a a great
exercise
that a business owner can take away and
start running with their
teams love that yeah that's a great
exercise so ass don't tell then we have
law two fail fast learn quick I feel
like that's quite to I write down here
safety to fail how do you actually yeah
how do you actually create this but yeah
fail fast Lear quick tell us a bit about
this well I think this came back again
my work with teamgb is that we we
weren't a professional hockey team so we
didn't have the money to go and travel
and and play exhibition games we
literally turned up to the world
championships and played our first game
and it was just like we don't even know
how we're going to perform against
Australia or Austria or Hungary or
whatever so let's test it let's test
everything let's try it and see
everything as a test the EV is an
opportunity to learn rather than going
into it thinking we cannot fail we
cannot lose this game if we lose this
game we don't make the make the next
stage it was just I guess it's it's a
little bit like Simon synic talks about
the the finite game versus the infinite
game you know the it's a constant
learning process and I think what
happens in recruitment with managers is
they interfere with the opportunity for
the consultant to learn because they
want it to be perfect so they want that
whole recruitment process to be perfect
in a in a kind of linear way and making
sure people don't drop the ball on that
so let's say there are 10 things they
have to do they drop the ball on two of
them the deal falls through you know
they want to kind of jump in and say
make sure that those two things don't
never happen again and they they get too
involved rather than again having that
retrospective conversation to say okay
look the the deal fell through let's
talk about the highlights let's talk
about what you did well well I found the
client I pulled two jobs blah blah blah
blah all worked you know I did all of
that uh so what were some of the things
you you could have worked on done
differently well the these two areas
here I think I dropped the ball or if
they don't know it that's your
opportunity to say well look I think
what happened here is that you missed
these two bits here and that's why it
fell out would you agree and um and then
use it as an opportunity for them to
develop that so they failed but they've
got to learn quick and you would hope
that they don't do that again if they do
it again then we probably have a little
bit of a challenge there with that
individual right if they're if they're
making the same mistake over and over
again there's a lack of
conscientiousness or whatever
but um so the failing fast learning
quick is just getting out of the way
essentially let's let's do it but you've
also got to create an environment or a
system that makes foul fast learn quick
work because if you're just
failing then it's just going it's just
you're doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
but if you're failing fast learning
quick then you've got to put a system in
place to learn quick which is for some
people it might be daily retrospective
conversations talk me through the
highlights of your day what went well
what's been challenging or it could be
weekly for your more senior Consultants
more independent achievers they probably
need a catch up every two weeks or a
month to have those retrospective
retrospective
conversations um because even high
performers they will get complacent we
see it in sports you know get complacent
they took the foot foot off the gas and
they up in a rut they can't they can't
make the plays they want to play or
score goals and then they start getting
the inner voice self chat you know so
there's a few things that we have to do
with faast Lear one is create
psychological safety create a safe place
for people to go out and try stuff and
also to be able to come back and not
feel like they're going to get battered
for it but actually come back and have
someone listen to them help them
understand what they did well also help
them understand what could have been
better and then make sure that they
execute on those
gaps so how do you actually do that is
it by is it by proving that that's
that's what you're doing for them
because like the way that you just said
that makes complete sense and I'm
thinking how how does one actually make
another person feels safe to fail and
you know where I end up is if you do
what you're saying it's just about doing
it and proving to that person that
they're not going to get battered
they're not going to be you know
embarrassed in front of everyone but
actually they're going to be uh
hopefully given an amazing opportunity
to learn on how they can get a different
outcome which is what they're aiming for
next time yeah is it just by doing what
you just said it always comes back to
the conversation always you know so
let's say
you know you're a
consultant and a deal fell through you
know why you dropped the ball on
something you didn't follow the process
you you got a little bit complacent and
you're thinking I've got to go and tell
my boss I've got to tell my boss I I
can't believe this it's going to you
know I promise this this was in my
pipeline you know I was depending on it
the team's depending on it and how am I
going to explain this to my boss now
there's two there's I mean there's two
extremes one is you're an idiot what
have you done
why why did you do this you know but
there's nothing better for the
consultant to come back and go here the
boss go okay let's talk about it let's
just talk about it because I you know
you you clearly did some things here to
get to this point in the sales
process yeah so I'd like to understand
that a bit as well so what that does is
it makes them think oh yeah there was
there were some things that I did that
work well it wasn't a complete failure
and now I know that those things I
should keep doing because they work
and then you you B so let's have a bit
of a chat about why this happened you
know what's your what's your opinion of
it why do you think it fell
through now they might make
excuses they might say well the
candidate wasn't honest with me or
whatever my question to that consultant
would be what is it you did or not do
that caused the candidate not to be
honest with
you because I don't want him to complain
about the candid I want him to take
ownership of the situation
and I oh well I suppose I could have
done okay well let's talk about that
then you know and it's done in a calm
way but
with in a firm way you know we we're not
it's not a fluffy conversation we're not
letting them off the
hook so for the next month then or when
we're working on this next project
whatever it is can I be confident that
I'm going to see that change in you
going forward that this won't happen
again that we'll make sure that we
follow the process is that cool yeah
you've you got it okay what what support
do you need for me to help you do that
we'll get back to the episode in just
one minute but today I wanted to tell
you about our partners sourcewell the
industry-leading business development
and head hunting platform I'm a
sourcewell user myself and it's been an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
crafting personalized Outreach it's not
only quick and easy but you can tap into
custom variables automate follow-ups and
use multiple channels like the phone
LinkedIn email and more to accelerate
results
users report an average increase of 56%
in qualified response rates and when
you're using it it's easy to see why AI
power tools like content coach and well
GPT improve your chances of not ending
up in spam something that's become
increasingly challenging with Google's
recent deliverability changes it also
tracks all of your activity into your
CRM keeps your data clean and lets you
know who you need to reach out to and
when so you can spend more time on what
you're good at recruiting not admin so
if you're serious about being the best
at what you do join me and thousands of
recruiters who have chosen sourcewell to
revolutionize their Outreach approach
book ad demo with sourcewell and
mentioned the recruitment mentors
podcast to enjoy an extra 50 phone and
50 email credits per user and this
exclusive offer will save you Circ £500
and more and it's only available until
March the 31st click the link in the
episode description or you can head to
source.com
demo and I guess that brings it into law
three right hold each other accountable
which I
think uh is is often I I I'm always
thinking about how I can do that
effectively with with my team and just a
team of four so like tell us a bit about
this hold each other accountable I think
most managers will
know they need to do it but can often
find it difficult to do it because it's
it's
hard yeah I find well it's it's hard for
some
people particularly if you
are more on the agreeable Spectrum you
know looking at against sort of
psychology here but if you look at the
five personality traits psychology one
of them being agreeableness and it's on
a spectrum so some leaders struggle with
accountability because it feels like
conflict or it feels like got a follow
up or what if I follow up with this
person they've let me down and D D D D
you know and if they have let me down
then what do I say do I put a
consequence in place do I have to put
them on a performance Improvement plan
you know what is the extreme here you
know because so we end up kind of just
avoiding that whole thing until
something happens and it becomes an even
bigger
problem so and then there are other
people who are really quite comfortable
holding people accountable they just do
it all the time you know and and
unfortunately for those managers their
emotional bank account is in massive is
a negative equity right because all
they're doing is where are you with this
what you doing where you going you know
what's happening with this what's
happening with this right well I've got
a problem with okay well let's fix that
what you need to do is this this this
and this right so when are you going to
get done by and it sounds like that and
it's just like being someone just being
getting jabbed it's like going in the
ring you know and just taking Jabs in
the face for you know 12 rounds whatever
so so there's a balance between ask
don't tell some people are really
comfortable with ask don't tell they
like the conversation but they take it
to such an extreme ex fluffy it's like
just this woolly conversation of just
going around and asking questions and
it's all nice and someone's sitting
there thinking this is what is this
therapy what's going on you know like
can we just get to the point um so
there's one extreme of that and there's
the Other Extreme of being too directive
and dactic with people so we have
to countability in ask don't tell it's
it's like drive one accountability is
about driving
performance and ask don't tell is about
engagement right so if we look at those
two things performance and engagement
we're trying to create a culture of
Engagement where people can engage
motivated and excited and it's a nice
place to work it's
supportive performance is about
challenge make me better you know drive
me push me you know we we want both and
what we often see in companies is that
they drive drive the numbers so
performance pushing it pushing it
pushing it and then we start to see a
little bit of burnout they do an
engagement score and everyone's upset
and not happy and wants to leave and
blah blah blah blah so they go oh so we
better do some engagement stuff now like
get everyone happy
um let's fill the office up with bean
bags and and table tennis tables and and
give everybody a you know a smoothie
when they turn up or whatever it is
they're doing and it's like the
flipflop and I liken that to when I use
I sock as an example football is a good
example maybe tennis the difference
between amateurs and Pros the biggest
difference is a professional ice hockey
player shoots the puck hard shoots it
accurately it's the difference the
amateur can shoot it hard or they can
shoot it accurately they they can't do
both at the same time it's really what
separates the pros from the amateures so
organizations that can do performance
and engagement
simultaneously is what makes them
difference different to the ones that
flip-flop and the companies I see that
just have a great would create a high
performance
culture are the have the ability to do
both really
well I really like that the yeah the
performance engagement so when it so
when it comes
to holding each other accountable yeah I
think you've given some I think you've
given some good examples of like what
that sounds like but like when is when
is the line of Andrew you know I felt
like I feel like you know would you
agree that we sort of
both understood that you was going to do
this differently so we didn't end up in
this outcome again but then they you
know do it again and again like when you
know when I don't know just trying to
think about when when is the line of
being like right I've heard this person
accountable they're not sort of changing
what we've agreed they said they' change
and we're still arriving at the same
outcome which isn't the outcome that
we're looking for well this this is
something we spend a lot of time on the
course because it's it's it requires
some feedback right so what we would
teach on the course is something like
well first of all we got to have
evidence right it's like oh this has
happened several times times you know
and I'm starting to get a bit pissed off
about it now it's like well it hasn't
happened several it's the first time no
no it's you know because there's no
evidence it's just a sweeping
generalization right yeah but what
you're describing is look I've noticed
that this is the third time we've had
this conversation about this situation
it's the third time it's happened and
last time we talked about it we said we
discussed that if this continued we were
going to have a different type of
conversation so that so you've you've
really given me no
other option you know and it might get
to that stage where it's okay this is
now verbal warning now any anybody
getting into that situation whatever you
do speak to HR because if it is getting
to that stage then you do need to get
advice on what the process is for your
business and and make sure that you
follow the process because otherwise if
it gets too General and sweeping
statements and you're always like this
you're always late you're always you
know dropping a ball here or whatever
then it will end in a messy place
obviously what I'm trying to do is help
managers avoid that it getting to that
point you know by doing the bench coach
daily train weekly Mentor monthly give
them all the resources coach them and
but if it gets to a point where this
person just isn't fit for purpose for
the job and they could actually do much
better in a different company or a
different uh industry then we should
really give them the opportunity to to
do that and then just quickly then
before we move on what have you found to
be the most effect it might I might be
jumping ahead and if so then we'll we'll
we don't need to cover it now we can go
through it uh shortly but what have you
found to be the most effective way to
hold hold people accountable in terms of
like consistency is it on like a weekly
basis is it on a daily basis do you know
what I mean it's whatever you agree with
the person right so hisam you you're
going to edit this podcast
today right you know as an example
you're going to edit it um when would
you like to have it edited
by yes I'd like to have this edited by
uh um end of play today before the
weekend okay and what are you hoping as
a the ideal outcome for
that is that it's uh ready to go ready
to be published um so I can then share
it on Monday okay so you you want to
share it on Monday so you mentioned
either get it edited by today or by the
weekend what would be better for you
today or by the weekend today definitely
okay what time would work for
you 5:00 5:00 so if we catch up about
5:30 today would that be be right just
to see where we're at and if it's ready
for yeah posting on Monday yeah that
sounds fine cool so that's today you
know it's going to change depending on
the project depending on the objective
depending on what's Happening um right
yeah it shouldn't feel
too like you know it should feel like
okay yeah let's do it yeah
nice all right so then we have law four
create Future
Leaders yes
well if you want to scale you've got to
Great Future Leaders there's there's no
doubt about it invest in your people uh
identify the ones that have got the
presence and the the gravitas and the
skills the natural skills that you think
are worth investing in and you know I
talk about the Mavericks and I talk
about the quarterbacks you know do you
want to Ronaldo running your team
because he's the best on your team and
you know smashing out the park and and
so on um or you want to Tom Brady
you know who's got that Presence at
gravitas who can quarterback everything
and that was always my goal with the
British team was to identify three to
four players that could be my core
leadership and I know that would hold
the team accountable as well when I
wasn't around so when you leave the
office you know and you want to go home
and you want to go and watch your kids
play football or you know take a holiday
or or just go home and have some dinner
you need to know that there are some
people around that can help you do that
so it's it's one identifying the right
profile of person who can
uh step into that leadership role and
then what sort of investment you're
going to make in them to help grow them
and if you if you look around your
business and you go well I just don't
have anybody like that I've got I've got
a few ronaldos I've got a few people
that are you know just making Target but
I don't I don't feel like I've got
anyone in my team that's got that
presence yet um you're probably going to
have to make an acquisition of some sort
um
ideally I always think it works better
when you've got someone homegrown who
can come through um I think most people
that listening to this would agree with
that they might have had some
examples where they've hired someone in
and and it's made a difference but
it's usually more senior level I
think um but if you can hire that person
even that consultant you know that
rookie for you grad you know you can
still see in their in them whether they
have the the potential to one be a
really good recruiter and two start to
step into have that maturity you can
just tell with certain people you can
tell by their presence by the way they
speak how they articulate um whether
they can show some leadership prowess
what have you found to
be if I'm what have you found to be like
useful experiments in terms of what I
mean by that is if I've got a team of
eight people and there might be you know
three or four people that I'm thinking
they're showing some of the things you
talking about but you know what can be
some good experiments on like extra
responsibility is that could give them
opportunities to see how they might
handle certain scenarios like some of
the things that we've spoken about is
there anything useful there that you
found I would always start bench
coaching you know if they're a good
performer just give them an opportunity
give them a framework for bench coaching
observe a few calls can you just go and
um you know hisim it's your you know
you've been in the business a year year
and a half or something like that and um
I've just turned up rookie in the
business and your boss says to you hey
can you just sit with Andrew for an hour
today and and just listen to some of his
calls give him some coaching you know
like how we do it you know just give him
some of that I would start with
that good then the next thing I would do
is um probably a daily setup you know
the Huddle in the morning hey can you
run a huddle for me I can't make it
tomorrow morning I'm taking my kids to
school can you uh can you run the Huddle
for me yeah here's a bit of a framework
you know for you to questions to ask
given that um and I would just keep
layering in different things you know
and give them a bit of coaching hey I
observed your huddle today got some
feedback for you you know or and I think
that's S no or you just ask him
questions you know tell me you did the
Huddle today how was it what was good
about it everyone left motivated and you
know whatever I was just going to say
like that's also from the individual
standpoint I think important because it
gives them opportunities to find out if
they enjoy doing those things as well
right rather than yeah like they're
being pushed into it or forced into it
which is often the case for a lot of
people yeah exactly yeah have a
conversation about it you know that's
the thing is to Prime them for that that
role not just drop them in and expect
them to swim but just give them give
them a little bit of rope to uh to do it
you know a few skills and techniques if
if you're if you're if you're role
modeling it this is the thing I always
talk about with yellow pages it was it
was such a brilliant organization to
work for like the training was
incredible and by the time I moved into
I was I moved straight into a regional
sales manager role so it was big a big
role and but I knew how to have the
conversations with people because my
boss had been having the conversations
with me so you start to create a culture
of of coaching and feedback and and
accountability and it just becomes the
way we do things around here it just it
just
takes takes a little bit longer to for
some companies to transform into that
so final law Foundation then always be
hiring yeah I think you know you I
always use the analogy of um well you
never know who you're going to be
working for and who's going to be
working for you for starters just be
nice to people so it's always be hiring
versus and also always be networking so
always think about your personal brand
always think about how you're showing up
in in different
situations um networking meeting people
people you know CEOs that I work with
they might want to step away from the
role you know if you've been a dict to
someone in the past and now you want
that person to be your md or I I find
that sales managers might have treated
someone badly in another organization
now that person's been brought in and
they got a report into that person I've
seen that happen before that was that's
awkward um so it's just the idea of
always be hiring is always be networking
always be thinking about how you're
showing up because you never know and
you know Ronaldo we talked about Ronaldo
but when Ronaldo joined Manchester
United it was like like this is the club
I'm joining because Sir Alex Ferguson
had been having conversations Ronaldo
for for years you know he was networking
he that was one of his the greatest
greatest things he he did was his
ability Network and Mentor people from
quite a young age and and nurture them
and develop them and so by the time they
joined the club he was like a father
figure to them you know so you never
know who how people going to develop and
grow and you'll see people out there and
you think right that that person there
that could be my future MD or that could
be my future leader or that could be
someone that could join us one day you
know um so just always be hiring always
have that mindset always be on the
lookout head on a swivel yeah love that
so to recap then the foundations the
five laws that sit under here are law
one ass don't tell law two fail fast
Lear quick law three hold each other
accountable law four create Future
Leaders and the final L we're just
talking about is always bearing so now
we come into the Playbook so talk about
so law six yeah have a have a game plan
and I write down here the five steps
because I think that's sort of part of
what you broke it down for so talk to us
a bit about have a game plan it sounds
obvious doesn't it to have a game plan
but it's important to have a game plan
and I think for Consultants or team team
leaders working with Consultants you
know think about your game plan over 90
days and again Step One is where do we
want to get to in 90 days or where do
you want to get to in 90 days what does
good look like for you where are you now
right so we've got a bit of contrast but
we've got a beginning of the journey and
and a destination it's really important
to frame that you know what is our
biggest problem right now you know so if
you're doing it at a business level look
what what's our biggest challenge right
now what are we struggling with downturn
in the market this that okay so where
where do we want to get to in the next
90 days so that's step one it's the
beginning it's the beginning of the
journey end of the journey get that
right and then the second step is
resources what resources do we need what
do we have you know don't recreate
things sometimes I go into organizations
I'm working with them I'm facilitating
these meetings and they're like we're
going to design a new training program
and then someone outse comes along and
says yeah but we we did that two years
ago we've got something in the archive
somewhere you know let's just use the
resources we've got rather than re
Reinventing the will so what resources
do we have what's missing and resources
can also be do we have the right Talent
you know so we might need to hire people
over the next 90 days or we want to hire
one more person or we want to bring in a
team leader whatever it is
uh brainstorming you know get your team
to come up with ideas
Innovation and you know the rules and
brainstorming anything goes get it on a
Post-It note flip chart let's get ideas
there or let's bounce some ideas off
each other just verbally and step
forward choose the best idea you know
make sure you choose the best option
debate it this is your opportunity to to
ask some challenging questions what if
if we go with this idea what if we go
this idea what if what are the upsides
downsides and often if people come up
with some crazy ideas through your in
they'll kind of work out that's probably
not the best way forward rather than
saying n that's not a good idea you know
we don't we don't want to crush ideas we
want to just get them to to think it
through and then step five is execute
you know what are we going to do
specifically what are the measures what
are the time frames and then then you're
into foul fast learn quick you're into
coaching I don't tell you know and well
we're getting into bench coach daily
train weekly mental monthly which are
the next three yeah I love that you I
think you will be like it's so easy to
to get bugged down in the weeds yeah and
like how many you know how many player
coaches right now that are listening how
many of their team are aware of what the
game plan is I don't know I think that's
what I say you know you don't have a you
don't have a motivation problem you have
a Clarity problem no one knows what if
they're doing right that's the problem
you know let's get clear on that and
there's a couple of things arstone tell
is about being a facilitator as well the
best leaders I've observed and worked
with are just brilliant facilitators
they can fac fa itate a conversation
like you're doing and and ask questions
and get people thinking hold them
accountable they can facil facilitate
group conversations and get people to
come up with ideas and use this
five-step plan that I talk about they're
really good at facilitating and that's
that's the I think the biggest the
biggest shift I see in leaders because
it's vulnerable right it's vulnerable
not to have all the answers but it
equally incredibly empowering we'll get
back to the episode in just one minute
but today I'm excited to talk to about
one of our partners fire fish the
recruitment CRM that accelerates
datadriven growth they have just
released their 2024 recruitment agency
report based on insights from over 200
agency leaders the report offers
unbelievable insights into forecasts for
the year ahead enabling you to refine
your strategy Based on data rather than
intuition here are some of the stats I
personally found interesting from the
report although industry optimism has
declined for the third in a row growth
signals remain positive with 84 % of
agency leaders expecting year-on-year
sales growth this year 47% of agency
leaders plan to use a contingency
recruitment model in 2024 and 70% of
agencies plan to use social sourcing as
their main candidate attraction strategy
in 2024 you can access your free copy of
the report and start making data driven
decisions about your business by
clicking the link in the show notes and
whilst you're there if you wanted to
check out how Firefish could help your
business grow this year they very kindly
offered a unique offer to our community
the recruitment mentals podcast that's
going to save you up to £1,000 and this
offer is only available until March the
31st you can click the link in the
episode description and you can also
head to Firefish software.com
slrm so let's go into law 7 you've
already mentioned it but I do think this
is when we're really getting um there's
a bunch of practical things already but
we we these are really practical things
which are Absol love and I do really
love this methodology of bench coach
daily so just because I know you've
already mentioned it but could you just
quickly just Define yeah bench coach
daily just so then we all understand
what what you mean by that it's it it's
on the sales floor observing sales calls
observing people you're looking for
every opportunity to provide positive
feedback if you're on the bench with
your team you have coaches that break
their players and they go back on the on
the ice just or the court feeling like
crap you know like they might feel a bit
of injection motivation probably the
stress hormone quarter old has put them
into action they're not in flow or in
the zone
um if if you don't have the opportunity
people say oh but I'm we're working
remotely we've got a remote team then
you know recording calls listening to
them but even blind coaching just having
a conversation which is tell me about
the three best calls you had
today that's it you let's talk about it
what was good about them what did you do
well I prepped for it I did this what
were the three worst calls you did today
well this one this one and this one
because the client was like this and
what would could you have done
differently you know but you can coach
blindly there's no excuse with whether
you're coaching remotely or or this or
that um so I I'm a I'm a big fan of
coaching remotely because I think one of
the biggest challenges for a billy
manager is how do I fit in the time to
coach people take an hour of my day when
I could make 30 40 calls now I'm
demonstrating two or three calls to
someone or I'm listening to three or
four calls you know both our
productivity have dropped
so you know we often see Billy managers
performance drop off a little bit um
when they go through the kind of
implementing the the techniques um but
if they can actually coach by listening
to calls and working through them or or
just asking the person tell me about the
three best calls you did today why why
were they good what was it you did that
made them good you know why I felt
really prepped for it I put a lot of
effort into it whatever it is or I was
just in a good mood you know I stood out
a good energy today
you know compared to yesterday my energy
was low and I just wasn't getting
anywhere with with anybody you know so
you know that advice you gave me about
standing up and making my calls and just
bringing energy to every call was
massive you know so that that was a big
highlight for me today stuff like that
okay yeah so this is all about yeah like
you said on the sales floor or in a
remote fashion you know on the day in
the moment so you you structured
um so you recommend structuring this
sort of feedback with fre steps yeah
so you've got uh uh step one what action
did you notice them doing step two what
was the impact or effect of that action
Y in step three what is the desired
outcome going forward performing that
action more less or more consistently
tell us a bit about that cuz I think
again yeah that's more direct in the
game feedback so it's less questions and
it's more opportunities to provide
positive feedback so his I've noticed
for the last year you've shown up
consistently on on LinkedIn as a result
that's built your personal brand you're
one of the go-to people in the
recruitment industry and going forward
you know I think you're going to you're
going to smash it going forward if you
keep doing
that that's that's kind of in the moment
you know three or four seconds I could
put that on a text to you at the end of
the day I could say to you Hisham the
questions you asked me today in the in
the podcast really got me thinking you
really got my my my conversation going
I'm really appreciative of that um it
really helped me think through and I
can't wait to listen to the podcast
podcast or more of your podcasts going
forward if I text you that you know it's
like I noticed that you put uh you pull
three jobs today you know on the system
that's awesome that's going to help you
get to the Target it's going to help you
save up your money if you you know you
close these deals and um save up money
for your for your wedding whatever it is
um that the person's focusing on a car
um and uh let's keep going for it you
know just keep that positive energy you
got to look for opportunities to give
positive feedback stop trying to fix
people you know that's what we see a lot
of you know most people feel bad enough
about certain things if they messed up
or whatever and at some point you're
going to have to give someone a kidney
blow you know some de some developmental
feedback you know which is same
structure I noticed that the impact of
it was and i' like us to have a
conversation about how we avoid that
happening again that's a tough
challenging ation but if it's in the mix
of five six positive you know you're
always in emotional bank accounts in
credit you should always be trying to
keep your emotional bank account in
credit because at some point you're
going to have to make some
withdrawals and this is what you're
talking about which is part of this
which I which I again I really like and
is really practical for people which is
all those examples that you gave her in
line with your advice which is keep
feedback evidence-based not subjective
exactly yeah otherwise you end up in
this sort of ping-pong match of you did
this you know several times you've done
this no I didn't yes you did no I didn't
yes you did you know it's like just cut
to the chase let's get let's get it
really clear and and choose your battles
you know no I love that and again like
just those examples that you gave they
may seem like small to you but could be
huge for the person receiving them right
yeah yeah absolutely massive in your
team we completely underestimate that
yeah so law eight train weekly y um and
I think you've even got which I've got a
picture here of like an example of
um what that might look like as well
which I'll be able to share but talk to
us a bit about this train weekly and why
why this is one of the laws I I would
say that this if you want Roi on your
time this is the one to double down on
and it's the one that gets most
neglected because of
time and I share a structure I won't go
into the structure now of Designing
training because we try and do it like
really quick on the course like do
follow these six steps show a video make
it funny share a war story
well you have you have six steps which
are set a clear objective and prepare
set the scene use a video to open
discussion challenge trainers with an
exper experiential activity share War
Stories set actions and ask for feedback
there're your six steps yeah we and
that's something we teach like sharing a
war story teach you how to tell a story
a funny story it's usually an experience
that was awful for you like the word
something you'd like to forget about but
actually when you tell it it's actually
funny you know and we can bring it to
life so we teach people how to tell
story in that way and find videos on
YouTube to illustrate your point and so
on to make your training which could be
a 30 minute training session once a week
but the point is if you take
professional sports you're on a training
ground 90% of the time you're playing
the game 10% of the time in recruitment
you're in the game 99% of the time train
so there's no wonder people start
getting fatigued and burned out and so
on so getting them together for half an
hour to do a structured training like we
like we teach but also just doing a
mastermind session you know where the or
Fishbowl exercise or just five of us sat
around and we go our biggest challenge
and let's say I'm in that group and
there are five other people and I I say
this is the biggest challenge I'm facing
right now and we just talk about it and
we try and come up with a solution
together that's training in itself for
for rookies it can be really good
training some of the best training I've
had is when we just throw a challenge
out on the table and we try and solve it
together or someone shares some gems
some nuggets you know the you know a
question I could ask or a way to get
past the gatekeeper or whatever it is
you know oh wow that's that's awesome
I'm going to try that today you know
that that can be energizing so doing
that once everyone knows Wednesday
morning 8:30 training happens that's
kind of what I yeah try encourage people
to do that that's really overlooked like
when we're speaking it's part of our
implementation system with with Hector
which is people are given a safe space
to learn each week by their manager and
then on a bi-weekly basis or all weekly
they're then getting together sharing
what they've learned ideas um and like a
lot of companies yeah Overlook like
really using the subject matter
expertise that they have within their
four walls just because you say to
someone like I'm here to support you
anything you need let me know doesn't
mean that they're going to ask for the
help exact or have the courage to ask
for it so creating intentional space
yeah and creating that I was just going
to say sorry like just create what
you're talking about is what we found is
like creating that intentional space to
do that knowledge sharing is often what
what people need and is is yeah a missed
opportunity particularly if because
there's just so many people where in
recruitment there'll be top performers
in your business right now and they're
doing certain things in a really great
way and there'll be other people in the
team that are struggling with that exact
thing but they don't know how the top
performer are doing it absolutely
right yeah so creating those moments to
share how people are doing what they're
doing and sharing the challenges is is
really valuable and I think that's what
you're doing brilliantly with your
mentors you know and so on bringing that
together that that environment that's
it's so this this is in the book but I
think just worth worth sharing so just
to get bring this to life a bit but
again you can see this in practice in
the book as well but so just to bring
this to Life as we close this out which
was so if the problem was not enough
pictures are resulting in closed deals
um and we want the outcome to be team
more confident pitching persuasively and
closing deals and then the benefit of
that will be a team uh will be earning
more commission thanks to increased Clos
deals what this trending session might
look like with your framework is um you
know first 5 minutes uh a couple of
minutes of discussion on what we think
is a you know single biggest challenge
uh causing not converting the leads what
um skill is holding us back then we
might watch a video that you would have
sourced online could be anything could
be a podcast could be um something you
found on YouTube then after that we're
going to do a bit of a roleplay in pairs
of interviewer and interview interviews
ask questions to make interview talkers
much as possible um you know do a bit of
a role play have people do this in a
safe environment then we have an
anecdote personal War Story uh for sort
of five or so minutes context find uh
presenting high pressure pitch obstacle
client name misspell on opening slide
solution adapt a mistake present as a
benefit for the client and then yeah
activity group discussion group War
Stories what's worth for you and Andrew
like share with us some of your biggest
challenges what did you do differently
um and then getting feedback from the
team how do you like this training what
could have done better so just to bring
that to life a bit and and what Andrew
recommends nice yeah and I I think thank
you you know the one of the things that
I find with training is particularly for
in
recruitment is wasn't it for them that
you got to tell them you know that it's
going to make you more money it's going
to make you more efficient it's going to
make you look cooler it's going to make
you build stronger relationships you
know you got to really share the
training cuz people are coming with
crossed arms it's on Zoom it's like why
are we doing this you know tell me
what's in it for me all of a sudden oh
now you got my attention I can make more
money with this or whatever it is you
know love that so then you've mentioned
it but then we have law n Mentor monthly
yeah get your people away from the game
you know take them for a walk coffee uh
lunch board room but get them away from
the game and if you if you have to do
this again it's S3 Legacy MBR style you
know the monthly business review which
usually is a check sheet of can be a
check sheet of
kpis that the art the art of a mentoring
conversation is to make it feel like a
conversation not not a linear kind of
check checklist or a a
structured kind of step-by-step
conversation that's the art is making it
conversational and the the science is is
the framework you know you're taking
people on a journey and they're always
coming up with a goal an objective
something they're going to execute that
you can hold them accountable against
that's that's the key with mentoring and
and mentoring is you know in the game
the bench coaching can be tough it can
be you can be driving people you can you
know like again youex Ferguson example
to find a different one but this kind of
angry Scotsman on the sideline barking
at his players pulling him out of
nightclubs and stuff like that um is
considered a father figure and it's
because he gave his players time sit
down let's talk and it's we've got 30
minutes 45 minutes we've got an hour
what do you want to focus on today what
role can I play in helping you achieve
that you know where are you now well
let's let's brain storm some ideas
together which of these ideas do you
think is the best one to go with I'd
like to try this okay what's the upside
of that well I think it help me do this
what's the downside well I might do this
okay I think I'll go with this idea okay
when do you want to implement it by next
week all right so if we catch up next
week on Wednesday at 5:00 is that cool
okay or next month or why don't we put
this in place for the next month and
we'll follow up on this on our next
mentoring conversation or next meeting
you don't have to call it a mentoring
conversation you call it a meeting the
fact is you're being a mentor and you
know team the best Billy managers once
they once they become selfless they
start to see themselves as Yoda and not
like Luke Skywalker you know you're
you're creating heroes in your business
so you're not being the hero look at me
I'm a billing manager and I've done look
how amazing I am you know it's you know
your Consultants of the Luke Skywalkers
you're the yod or yian or the
whatever whatever kind of analogy you
want to use but but you you've got to be
feel like that's your role to help
people transform and I remember
distinctly I distinctly remember
thinking with Team GB that regardless of
results we get that these people gone on
Journey for the next three to four years
with me and they're going to come out of
this transformed like and we've got
people working for Google in California
we've got who run their own companies
pts that become celebrities you know
we've got
um you know Jack larsson's working at
Boston Consulting now as a partner I
mean we've got you know developed these
people so I think see the see your
organization and their experience of
your leadership as a conduit to
something greater than they could ever
imagine and they'll remember you for
your life that's your
legacy yeah I love that I just I just
what I really think is important which I
think again is often missed is just like
you said taking time away from the game
CU often times we're talking about bench
coach daily and stuff yeah like I feel
like sometimes particularly in
recruitment you might find that often
times you're
your conversations with your managers
are like really just in the weeds of
stuff and exactly I think having this
space like you said to Mentor monthly
and have more of these open
conversations yeah just for the
individual on you know having those
meetings it's I don't know it's just
also really
um yeah to not always be talking um
about the weed so law 10 then to close
us out stay in the zone yeah which you
got things like manager the Mist you had
the white Mist the Red Mist talk to us
about staying in the zone
so obviously using a sports analogy here
and I experienced the white Mist as an
athlete where things just seem to close
in you're Paralyzed by the fear of
failure you know and for a consultant
that might be you know I just don't want
to make the call I don't want able to
hear me I don't want you know what's the
client going to say you know you know
whatever you get this kind of white miss
this fog you can't find your words you
know that you can speak and articulate
yourself but for whatever reason it's
just I can't get it out everyone's The
Whole World's listening to me Red Mist
is more understood because it's more
about anger and exerting energy outwards
so white Miss is like it's what I talk
about managing the miss my book you know
where white Miss is like inward energy
you go into yourself you got the inner
voice man the red Miss is like outward
energy you become aggressive you get
angry so dropping into the Zone dropping
into flow where we get this heightened
level of focus uh self-awareness
actually drops down ego drops off
preuner cortex starts to become less
engaged and we get in the zone and with
you know for a consultant that's they're
just in their flow they're making calls
the words are coming out they're just
building rapport with everybody they
speak to the energy is just awesome and
so for for a team leader you got to
create that environment where people
feel again it comes back to
psychological safety but as a leader you
know telling a story presenting to a
group of people the most successful
leaders typically are really good at
presenting giving feedback and so if we
go into ourselves andg the white Mist it
won't land it won't resonate people
won't take you seriously and equally if
you get angry and shout and bark at
people all the time there's a time and a
place by the way way to shout and bark
consciously not unconsciously
consciously firm with presence
um but uh yeah having that presence that
gravitas you know being in the zone is
also about presence it's about walking
the room owning the room nonverbal
presence you know command love
it they the 10 laws they the 10 laws I
got to go take my kids to a hockey game
now I got to shoot off unfortunately I
could talk to you all day is no no I
love it I think um so you know
everything that we just covered is in
this book it's it's $9.99 I think you
know you what you've done a really good
job with is it's super practical There's
real life examples with real billing
managers in here that you brought to
life there's actual practical like
Frameworks that you can maybe use in
your next mentoring conversation or your
bench coach daily conversation so um
yeah like we'll make sure that you can
grab this book with a link in in the
show notes but Andrew I think you know
kudos to you on like I I do truly
believe that these types of people in
our industry are some of the most
underserved under supported people
agreed so you know equipping these types
of people with Frameworks and systems
and tools that they can use y to help
them get more out of their people will
hopefully mean we have more people uh
you know enjoying and finding the fun in
this role thriving yeah cuz yeah I think
um I think that's a big part of the the
problem rather than people saying my
manager was ship well how much support
did your manager get on how to be a
better manager and a better Coach right
so exactly exactly yeah thank you really
enjoyed it and and thanks for coming
thanks for been a pleasure and keep just
love your work Isam keep doing what
you're doing